i have to tell you that finalist wyatt
pike
will not be competing in the competition
he had to drop
out but we wish him the very best okay
wyatt pike drops out of american idol
for personal reasons
while the judges give an update on luke
bryan after he
test positive for covid19 he's totally
good
i think he's going to be all right i
think we'll be be seeing him next week
monday marked the abc singing
competition's first night of live shows
where the top 16
battled it out for a spot in the top 12.
but at the top of the show it was
announced that wyatt had dropped out of
the competition for
unspecified personal reasons now leaving
only 15
singers competing for the coveted spots
[Music]
in a pre-taped episode on sunday wyatt
crushed his cover of kings of leon's use
somebody
i really believe in you i think whatever
happens you are already
you're it you're on your way to
something big my friend i'm telling you
wyatt you're going to be able to do
music for the rest of your life
wyatt has not commented on his exit on
social media
but he did share pics from his hometown
park city utah on
instagram five days ago writing quote
something to feel this through home
thankful for the roller coaster i'm on
today
but wyatt wasn't the only one absent
during monday's live show
i certainly want to be in the judges
table and something that i love
i love doing i love being on the uh on
the ground floor
of these artists coming in and watching
their dreams start to come true
being a part of it and you know being
there with lionel and katie i mean
the our chemistry is so natural so real
so fun and um i just uh i wouldn't
you know i wouldn't admit i wouldn't
miss being at that judges table for the
world
luke bryan also called out due to his
recent covet 19 diagnosis
you're magnetic on stage there's no
there's no doubt about it
former american idol judge paula abdul
filled his seat for the night and
after monday's live episode judges katy
perry and lionel richie shared an update
on how the country singer is holding up
he was texting us he's blown up our
phones every whole episode
some of it we can't even say because we
can't say half of it
but he agreed with everything and you
know he was just giving critiques
at home i guess alone in his room luke
revealed monday morning that he'd tested
positive
but it seems like he may be one of the
lucky ones who didn't get hit with the
symptoms quite as badly as others
he's totally good i think he's going to
be all right i think we'll be
be seeing him next week and while katie
and lionel
are looking forward to having their old
pal back on the panel
they had mad love and appreciation for
paula's work on monday's show
vel did a great job she did a great job
as for paula who was on the show from
its inception in 2002
through 2009 she said the whole thing
came together really fast
i didn't have time to think about it
because it was literally it happened
i got a call on friday night and and i
was worried because i was getting my
second vaccine i thought
oh my god what if i have a reaction and
i was able to move my
my appointment to saturday night and
that so yesterday i was feeling kind of
crampy but
today i woke up fine and um it was it
was fun
and while the guest spot on idol gave
her those throwback feels
she jokingly said it was easier to share
a panel with katie and lino than it was
to share it with her old co-stars simon
cowell and randy jackson
i love being on this panel with this
panel tonight
it's way different than the panel i was
on that's for sure